if a woman genuinely repents she has a
right to ask for a virgin guy in islam
just to make that clear she she has a
right but i'm going to say something she
doesn't have the same ability i i'm
giving advice to a girl on how to get
married she's very overweight and i told
her to lose weight in a very respectful
and nice way i told that to some girl i
went to meet for a wrister she was like
you should tell her to just love herself
it's complete bs
i've done the seven day free trial of
the qurani app and it exceeded all my
expectations alhamdulillah i was worried
that was an overrated product that's
what he thought until he tried it what
was the system you can build a habit
with the quran buy seven day free trial
bonuses not credit card details required
at all and you decide for yourself is it
overrated or is it underrated all right
guys i have here the muslim andrew tate
wow as you can see
i'm joking this guy
you like uh we believe
we believe um you are much better than
him
because you're a muslim
so let me ask you a question he was
talking about that things people have
got things
muddled up
yeah
so let me ask you a question
you know you look a bit sharp here you
look like you're looking for a second
wife
maybe one day maybe one day okay you're
married no not yet
would you say you're polygamous by
nature
i think to an extent if all men tapped
into like their real desires yeah and if
they could have the power not all men
lots of men if they could tap into their
desires they would actually go for that
but the thing is lots of men cannot do
that because they're not strong enough
or powerful enough right but if you look
at kings of old for example some of
these kings had 500
girls or harems right i'm not saying
that that's islamic be right you know
obviously we have our own take on that
but as far as i'm aware i'm not the best
at muslim knowledge i do have quite a
bit
but as far as i'm always up to four and
that's open to debate obviously yeah um
but yeah if if you if you were really
strong and you had a lot of money and
that's why
for example these arab guys do it right
they're islamic they're religious but
they can do it and they do it there's a
lot of people there's a lot of men who
don't have the money to do it as well
but are you polygamous by nature meaning
that would you say would you agree that
most men are polygamous by their nature
that if they could they would have a
second or third wife before flight yeah
so
am i right or wrong saying that i would
say you're right and i'm a big fan of
biology people ignore biology and people
ignore science
i think science and religion can go hand
in hand
and the reality is
you know like i'm going to be very crude
men like to spread their seed right they
like to have lots of children when
possible and if possible yeah and
that my genghis khan example he had 12
000 women right and
12 000 yeah and that that
any animal in the animal kingdom we're
not animals right but obviously we're
part of nature and we have very similar
tendencies right
and
in line with that lots of men would love
to have lots of children by lots of
different women to differentiate their
genetic poor and this is
factual based on scientific evidence but
again it's just that lots of men can't
because
it costs a lot to manage your wife okay
okay look i can't i won't assume
separate discussions yeah
every man
would want to
they would not say i won't or i wouldn't
do it i think there's a very rare man
there's an exception
i agree i agree majority of men are
polygamists by nature
now
you if a woman is watching this if you
just came and said oh you're a
misogynist or et cetera why are men
polygamous where does this come from
well if you yeah if you was to say
you're a misogynist i think that's just
an emotional response it's very easy to
label someone something very quickly and
the bar to call someone a misogynist is
very low these days yeah right
but
again going back to the why
you see your burger yeah you start
salivating you feel hungry why could
they hurt you you create a woman to
burgers no no no no no no no no no or
anything anything let's say fresh air if
you didn't have fresh air for a long
time yes you would crave it because
that's our natural human instinct yeah
women
tend to like one guy
they're more they're a lot more well it
depends on the circumstances right if
you break it down so
these days in the western world women
are treating as much as men if not more
and that is the fact they know what
they're cheating more than men
why is that official studies by the way
yes yes yes and the reason is one is
very easy the things that no fault
divorce right there's things like dating
apps and instagram right even mismatch
you know allows things like that back in
the day
if you were someone's wife you were
under hijab you were in his house you
would not leave
without his permission i'm not saying
that that's the optimal scenario
religiously but that's just how the
world was right these days
if your wife has instagram i'm sorry to
say there's lots of people siding into
the dms and they're better than you they
can offer her more money than you and
under those circumstances women are not
monogamous
at the same time they are i have a
theory yes i believe women are still
monogamous by nature the reason they are
becoming
polygamous is the following reason it's
a theory yeah and i believe it's quite a
strong theory if anyone can develop me
please come ahead yeah go ahead
when men are polygamous
what happens is usually so let's imagine
a man
and a woman they're in a relationship
yeah outside let's not put islam are
non-muslims yeah that guy is there for
one reason yeah
she thinks he loves her
he doesn't he's there for one reason
once he gets what he wants he says you
know what i don't think we're compatible
a lot of arguments happen he breaks the
map he breaks the relationship up yeah
she is under the assumption of what i
was in a relationship and we was not
compatible so he moved on yeah she meets
another guy yeah the guy has the same
agenda she meets another guy the guy has
the same agenda by now she's got three
body counts and it's going up what she
doesn't realize is that because she sees
men acting in that way then they start
rebelling and saying men are trash why
are men trash because you have made
yourself so accessible so easily that
men are there's no responsibility i can
just go ask you i'll take you the first
date a couple of days and have what i
want so why on earth would i stay with
you i'll be committed to you so
therefore
men the woman's body counts are quite
not as bad as a man's but i believe it
stems from this because women are
monogamous monogamous by nature and they
are looking for that romeo and they
realize every romeo they come across is
not romeo about fraud so therefore what
they're doing is they're thinking you
know what i've had four body counts and
all of these men have come and used me
i'm going to become a excuse my language
hoe so therefore i'm going to go do what
they're doing but what they don't
understand is that the more you do that
the more your pair bonding reduces
because when women have intimacy they
release a hormone called oxytocin yeah
which is which helps pair bonding and
studies show that women who have
one partner or one yeah sure you can
have one
so a woman who has who is married who is
a virgin has 80 more likely to have a
relationship lasting more than a decade
yeah so what women don't understand is
that the way
men
sleeping around and by the way it's both
haram in islam yes they're both it's
kind of it's coming to punishment
but you the reason you're doing that you
are shooting yourself on the feet it
doesn't affect the man as much because
in his biology and the way he's
programmed he can have multiple wives
yeah so the point i'm trying to say is i
believe it stems from there
you know what i agree with you a lot a
lot in fact almost like 98
the the only thing is firstly uh
is firstly a lot of people aren't very
smart yeah in society and the way i
think we need to understand the
underlying principles of why things are
you know people take a religious sign
i'll give you a small example every girl
when she married these days she says we
were created in pairs that's like a
catchphrase these days yes yeah it's on
pogba's it's on wedding cards it's on
wedding cakes everywhere
and she will have had lots of guys and
she's going to say this new guy guy
number 134 yeah is my new soul mate
that's not how it works and that that
ayah doesn't even necessarily mean that
for example
we were and we created you and pits
i think the quran is very poetic it is
very metaphorical it does not
necessarily mean that okay and it does
not mean that
there was some special soulmate created
for you soul mate myth is romanticism
but that's an example of how societal
conditioning can
mean it could literally be referring to
chromosomes it could be written
it can even mean refer to a man and a
woman
yeah does it mean it's it's because
otherwise you've got the murray in two
threes and fours yeah it doesn't
contradict that or doesn't it
yeah it doesn't it doesn't necessarily
mean there's one special guy out there
for you right and vice versa but the
point is not that they might be but that
one special guy can also be special for
other women as well because by getting
married again you know you know here's
an interesting thing
for a couple of women here's an
interesting fact more people believe in
a soul mate myth yes than god
yeah like in the western world okay
official studies again interesting and a
lot of these things are official studies
but we listen to societal messaging i'll
give another example of societal
messaging
the body positivity movement
i i'm giving advice to a girl on how to
get married she's very overweight and i
told her to lose weight in a very
respectful and nice way yeah i told that
to some girl i went to meet for a
wrister yeah she was like you should
tell her to just love herself
that is complete bs okay she no matter
how much she loves herself she cannot
get a guy by staying fat and loving
herself a lot that's just not how
reality it is next time you visit this
rich star tell her that next time she
meets a guy for marriage if he's five
foot four yeah
and she tells him oh i think you're a
bit short for me tell him to love
himself too yeah there's there's a lot
of double standards out there some are
some are wrong and some are right and
one thing is men hate hoes it's a fact
no one will say this to you men hate
hoes oh sorry okay so men men do not
like women yeah they have slept around a
lot and again that is rooted in biology
because
that would put the risk of paternity
it would increase the risk of paternity
right so for example if if a girl's been
with 10 guys
biologically you're like
there's a good chance that's not my kid
i should not invest in her i do not like
her your feelings of love and romance do
not come
one of the quickest ways to turn a guy
off is to be a hoe right
and that is a fact of life a guy
sleeping around and a girl sleeping
around in a practical sense has very big
differences it is both a sin
very clear yeah we're not saying what
we're seeing is that
biologically and the way allah has
created us one has a greater impact on
the uh on females in the males this
doesn't mean that the sin is not the sin
and by the way just to make it clear
that the i in the quran allah talks
about that chase woman for chase men is
not talking about virgin girls if a
woman genuinely repents she has a right
to ask for a virgin guy in islam just to
make that clear she she has a right but
i want to say something she doesn't have
the same ability
that so maybe if you
if you've been with 20 guys and you've
magically turned religious and this is
this happens a lot and the reason is
girls realize their mistakes
but your your emotional tendencies
are going to be worsened if you tell
someone honestly that you've been with
20 guys and you told them that you've
changed religiously
lots of guys will not put up with that
yeah right because
if you don't why i'm going to ask you a
question
why is it okay for a man to sleep around
but when it comes to a woman it's not
the same why does a man reject there are
lots of again it all goes back to
biology as a woman
it's very easy to sleep around as a guy
it requires a lot of skill money lurks
health etc but that's not even the base
reason the reason is men don't get
pregnant
so women get pregnant so if she's
sleeping around with 20 guys what's the
chances of you being the father of that
child five percent if you're sleeping
around with lots of girls yes
yeah i'm just giving up
and you know but again it is it comes
down to biology i'll give a small
example of biology people respect a
strong physical man that doesn't
necessarily have much to do with
religion i don't think you should talk
about me
[Laughter]
but as in if you if you want to see a
guy who's six foot six and has huge
muscles yeah you will not get rude to
him that had nothing to do with religion
not exactly but that's in a woman's
nature she's hypergamous by nature so
she looks for see the thing is very
interesting we accept the woman the way
they are their hypocrites by nature they
look for a man who is tall strong leader
provides protects yeah but then when it
comes to our nature of being
we get shamed
by nature and um for example i believe
everyone explains my nature we're blamed
for it the same goes with fat shaming if
i went to a girl and i said you know i
think you should lose a bit of weight in
a respectful way you know what i'll be
like how do you say that to her but
she's actually gonna be the same girl
that come and see me i want a guy that's
middle of six foot two yeah so the thing
is why is it double standards why is it
when it comes to a woman's weight
because you can control your weight i
can't control my height
i think there's two reasons one is women
are more emotional right
it's true are you misogynist now no it
is true it is absolute fact men go to
war they fight their emotions and they
go to war they they bullets flying by
and you will still charge to the front
line if you believe in the cause yes a
woman cannot do that to the same extent
some woman
there's exceptions to the rule so if you
i want llc so i'm kind of smart yeah but
if you look at like normal distributions
the normal distribution for male bravery
is way higher than female bravery it's
just how it is of course you might get
exceptions
so when a woman hears
you need to lose weight she takes that
personally she gets more emotional when
i hear that i'm a bit chubby nowadays
i'll be like okay you know what i i need
to go to the gym yeah it's as simple as
that i get told that's how it is i have
to do it i'm a doer i'm not i'm not
going to try to be a talker or go like
oh no you know what you shouldn't have
that preference that's your preference
okay and that's how it works so that's
thing number one and the second thing is
the sisterhood
the sisterhood feminism it's an echo
chamber yeah all these girls are cancer
all these girls telling each other
just accept yourself just love yourself
it's not good
now feminism is so strong we have
somehow convinced
fashion outlets to put pictures of big
beautiful women i'm not saying that
salah or whatever obviously you're
surrounded you should not have pictures
out there in society anyways yeah in a
religious sense but that's told
we we managed to conv
the sisterhood has managed to convince
some people that big is beautiful these
days
complete yes no no no no i disagree with
you it can be yeah because unitards and
there are different men generally
generally generally general generally i
understand but there's operations
some women can't control their weight
for a variety of health reasons now
let's be real there are medical reasons
yeah okay so that can happen but i
understand where you're coming from
there are exceptions to the war we don't
want our sisters who are watching some
might be overweight they should work on
it yeah but if they can't they shouldn't
be made sorry for being a bit rude
but they shouldn't be made to feel okay
there is someone for everyone just to
make that happen
if you want to increase your marital
success in terms of choosing someone yes
you have to cultivate yourself according
to the other gender it's just how it is
as a guy if you're poor and you're fat
you're not going to get a lot of options
you have to work on yourself to become
educated good looking have some money
have some assets be able to provide a
good lifestyle have a sense of
leadership okay on the female side it's
the same if if all men go the same
because we don't i don't when i look for
a potential i don't care how much money
she makes yeah no no no no i was going
to say it's the same logic in the sense
that you have to improve okay so if a
guy wants as a feminine woman yeah if a
guy wants a girl who's not a hoe yeah if
a guy wants a girl who's sweet and
smiley yeah yeah whenever some girl asks
me what do you want i say i just want a
sweet and smiley woman not obedience we
look for business
we look for a woman who's obedient and
when i'm in obedience people get this
notion of like i go home and i punch in
the face agreeable
i'm not i'm talking about for example as
a man if i come and say i would not like
you to go to holiday with your friends
for example the way your dresses are
made maybe provocative can you do it i'm
trying to say i would look for that and
every man looks for that so yeah what
it's okay because at the end of the day
that's what i look for but some women
will say well hold on a second who are
you to give those rules you're the same
woman who within your nature you look
for a guy who's taller protector
provider you look for these things i
don't blame you for that but you're
blaming me for the things that i look
for you know what i'll tell you guys a
quick story here
so the internet
is amazing and it's really bad the insta
the internet has caused this cancer in
many ways right because it's an echo
chamber people can share lots of
messages really quick and we all have a
confirmation bias where we look at
things that align with our views and we
go like you know what this is right this
person is 100 right but that's just
because we think we're right right yeah
so back in the day i used to be a very
like romantic person i used to think
women are all
sweet nice and everything spice or
whatever the phrase is
did someone hurt you see see
that's the thing that that gets brought
up the first phrase that gets thrown at
you yes did someone hurt you yes the
answer is yes and the reason is yeah
that's what helps you learn yes but let
me just i will tell you i was like
before islam i lived in two decades of
yeah yeah yeah there was a time of my
life where for example some girls hurt
me yeah i'm trying to say and i didn't
look the way i looked or was in the path
of the dream
so i did the reason i'm asking it is
because sometimes what happens is you
can use it in a healthy way and channel
that energy into making yourself a
better man and that's what you have to
do hundred percent i'm trying to say
yeah so it's understandable but again
these the reason i'm asking you that is
because these women get upset and they
are the same woman who have caused for
example when he was a good guy yeah like
say the good guys finish life etc they
didn't want to know you yeah do you have
to say so they it's like they caused
that spiral yeah and then when they make
a man
like and i believe andrew t is a part of
that i believe he was hurt when he was
young
i don't think you have to get hurt right
it's just seeing reality for what it is
i'll give an example if you get rejected
by an assessment center like an
interview or something
you don't have to get hurt but you learn
from it next time the chances of you
doing that
successfully is a lot higher yes it's
all it is you just have to learn from
whatever your experiences are what your
mistakes are any any endeavor in life
you mess up you learn yes you fail out
of business you mess up you learn yes
you fail at squatting right you're
failing at 100 kgs you go again and you
learn right so it doesn't necessarily
mean you have to get hurt yeah but all
it is is where we come especially when
we're younger we we have lots of social
conditioning around us oh buy her
flowers i'll take her to a 200 pound
date whatever and then one day i'm mad
about 30 40 pounds you realize that
doesn't even work man that doesn't even
work what it's about who's taking you on
a date see and it's nuances it's a small
it does work but after a certain point
after a certain point in time
one thing for example yeah i learned
that at the start it doesn't matter
about how much money you have at the
start it's about how how much of a good
leader you are and then the money
thing that you're okay but girls girls
do look like generally they look at
money yeah yeah i agree and it's
beautiful for us like if i just get your
foot in the door for example like me
like i love my wife yeah i know she's
the most beautiful woman on this planet
yeah yeah if she was if her job was
collecting like dustbin for example yeah
i wouldn't care i don't care i would not
care but for a woman it's not the same
viewers collecting that's what two older
sisters watching at home that's pretty
she telling her friends hey
my uh husband to me is the attachment
collector so all the sisters
believe our words to all the sisters
watching at home we do not care if you
work at mcdonald's all the sisters that
said no to him no no no where he is now
what we care about what we care about is
you being smiley agreeable exactly i'm
not handsome like this guy i'm not
really taking glasses i'm not being not
being a hoe right yes um
and
but what about men why when men do it
they get away with this this is what
sisters are going to be asking why is it
why when men do it they get away with it
because we don't get impacted the same
way
it's a fact it's a fact yeah at the end
of the day again this doesn't mean
because in the sight of allah you commit
a sinner you're a man or a woman you die
on it it's peak for you oh you're an
islamic state yes madness manga like his
happy days yes
slash slash yeah okay
yeah there's pete you get me there's
official studies that are done on this
that doesn't definitely islam yep the
impact might affect the woman more but
in the sharia if you get caught man's
getting less nice yeah in islam
obviously obviously 100 they're both
huge sins
male or women that's what maybe alco
but yeah
on a scientific level there's studies a
woman sleeping with three men is
equivalent to a man sleeping in 60 women
in terms of emotional impact obviously
it can be that is difficult to measure
um
but that's just what one study says
that is an insight yes yes when it comes
to pair bonding like we said before a
woman woman
release oxytocin which is which helps to
pair bonding and the more intimate
partners she has it's like a knife going
numb it doesn't work uh not now um
blunt blonde it's going blunt yeah it
doesn't do the job anymore and that is
the reason why women tend to when
they're in these marriages or sing they
do not know how to love anymore they
don't know and it has a greater impact
on it i mean that's it i mean the muslim
i mean you're better than andrew table
android you get me so what should we
call you what's your name moment
moment moment moment movement martial
there's a member
you know you know how should they
approach you and maybe you have to speak
to them the father of course yes yes so
tell us a bit about yourself maybe
somebody sisters sisters out there i'm
six foot six foot one with shoes on
sisters out there i'm 62. yo you're
amazing okay so let's see
sisters out there how do you i'm 23. 23.
marshall you're young yeah sisters out
there genuinely not not yeah
stop relying on your instincts
stop relying on the internet and
feminism and feminism and stop relying
on your friends yes right
follow your dad genuinely
but i think
you know
in in islam we have the system of diwali
or the brother oh yes your dad wants the
best for you that is not your enemy my
sister got married alhamdulillah she's
in a great marriage
the reason is one she didn't she never
put herself out there too much so she
never got that much more attention now
when she's with her husband and her
husband gives her attention it's amazing
it's amazing so a woman's beauty is in
protection she should be wasn't getting
she has to be protected
a woman that is protected by her father
by her brother whatever and then
transferred to her husband yes yes is
something we really value we are looking
for that woman who's been protected from
all this weird social conditioning we
want a woman to protect i'll give an
example i'm i'm doing a decent job you
know i have lots of money stored away in
investments and stuff
how many wives do you want i'm not i'm
not trying to be arrogant
how many wives you'll be honest i think
i'll if i go really rich or maybe you'll
be able to afford two but for now it's
just one it's just one thing that's
that's that's that's good he's in halal
and you're going to do in the right way
you're not going to have a side check or
a mystery
you're going to do in the right way i
was going to give an example yeah lots
of lots of student goals yes can
outspend me they're going to hackathon
you know it goes with a job on and
everything it's student loan money you
know they just get money thrown at them
they haven't even worked a day in their
life they get money from that though but
it's like that it's easy for a woman all
you have to do is wear me you you have a
head start you have a headstock you do
you do and if you abuse it yes right
it's going to catch up to you yes and
honestly i think you know the korean
myth is a bit of a lie yeah like you
know everyone i'm a guy i don't even
like my career there's a study done this
book here it's called miss educational
woman yeah yeah there was a study done
of 100 000 men and women in uk and usa
over 30 years they found out that women
are less happier since the rise of
feminism yeah what does that show you
women prefer bro not to work they don't
want to work wrong yeah i don't want to
work the only reason though you have to
work well
i have to work you have to provide them
yeah the point is this you'll be so the
massive lie of a career woman you're
going to reach the age of 30 35 where
you cannot have kids anymore because
you're not as fertile as you was when
you were young and now it's harder to
find somebody and on top of that this
whole notion of career your career is
not going to be there
don't call for this massive lie buy this
book i i recommend two books for the
sisters beauty sick and james dooley the
miseducation of woman it really exposes
that anytime you look for solutions
outside the quran and the sunnah you're
bound to suffer and now we are seeing
men going to red pill you're going to
suffer as well yeah you're going to
suffer trying to be andrew tate brother
who the hell is understand he's a no
value man i've said this before the guy
is a no value man to a muslim man he's
got nothing to offer he commits become a
shirk yeah he's the worst of the worst
unless he accepts islam and repents you
know he might be better than us so i
think that's it
if you get married call me to any cat
yeah make sure there's lobster in the
wedding please yeah and charlotte king
prunes all right so next time for uh